Hallo! Heute gibt es ein paar Tipps
in Sachen Logik.
Häufige Fehlschlüsse aus dem Alltag,
damit ihr in der nächsten Diskussion
nicht auf falsche Argumente
hereinfallt.
Das Autoritätsargument.
Angenommen, jemand sagt dir:
"Du darfst
unter keinen Umständen lügen,
das sagte schon
der grosse Philosoph Immanuel Kant."
Was antwortest du darauf?
Frag nach, wie Kant
seine Behauptung begründet.
Hat er gute Gründe,
kannst du sie nachvollziehen,
wenn nicht,
musst du nicht glauben, was er sagt.
Er ist ein berühmter Philosoph,
hat aber nicht unbedingt recht.
Umgekehrt gilt auch nicht,
dass Kants Philosophie falsch ist,
nur weil er in seinen Schriften
Behauptungen aufstellt,
die z.T. rassistisch
oder frauenfeindlich sind.
Wer das behauptet,
bringt ein sog. Ad-hominem-Argument.
Er zielt auf den Menschen
und nicht auf das, was er sagt.
Wie wenn du
mit einem Vegetarier streitest
und sagst,
Hitler sei auch Vegetarier gewesen.
Das stimmt zwar,
ist aber kein gutes Argument.
Auch schlechte Menschen
können wahre Überzeugungen haben.
Dann der Sein-Sollen-Fehlschluss.
Als Gegenargument gegen Vegetarismus
hört man ja oft:
"Schon unsere Ur-ur-ur-ur-Vorfahren
ernährten sich von Tieren."
Das stimmt vielleicht, heisst
aber nicht, dass es richtig war
und wir auch heute noch
Fleisch essen dürfen und sollen.
Aus einer blossen Tatsache
folgt nie eine Aufforderung,
aus einem Sein folgt nie ein Sollen.
Klar, wenn man
keine Alternative zu Fleisch hat,
der Körper das Fleisch zum Überleben
bräuchte, wäre es anders.
Aber die blosse Tatsache, dass der
Mensch immer Fleisch gegessen hat,
ist kein Grund,
damit weiterzumachen.
Das Dammbruchargument.
Gegen Veränderungen wird oft das
sog. Dammbruchargument angeführt.
Jemand sagt z.B.: "Wenn homosexuelle
Menschen heiraten dürfen,
darf man bald auch das eigene
Haustier oder Auto heiraten."
"Da sage ich nur:
Wehret den Anfängen!"
Oder jemand sagt: "Setzt sich
künstliche Befruchtung durch,
werden bald
nur noch Designerbabys geboren."
"Das ist der Anfang vom Ende."
"Es kommt zu einem Dammbruch
und plötzlich ist alles erlaubt."
Solche Dammbruchargumente hört man
oft, v.a. bei moralischen Fragen.
Wichtig zu wissen: Diese Argumente
sind nicht prinzipiell falsch,
sie können richtig sein, aber
wer ein solches Argument vorbringt,
muss jeden einzelnen Schritt, jede
Konsequenz auch begründen können.
Er oder sie muss zeigen,
warum A zu B,
B zu C und C zu D führt.
Meistens liegen diese Konsequenzen
in der Zukunft, sind also ungewiss,
was eine Begründung
besonders schwierig macht.
Der zirkuläre Beweis.
Angenommen, jemand sagt:
"Abtreibung ist Mord,
Mord ist moralisch schlecht,
also ist auch Abtreibung
moralisch schlecht."
Ein logisch gültiges Argument -
trotzdem ist es nicht überzeugend.
Die Schlussfolgerung nämlich, dass
Abtreibung moralisch schlecht ist,
steckt schon in der ersten Annahme,
also im Satz "Abtreibung ist Mord."
Schon das Wort Mord allein
ist nämlich abwertend.
Das Ziel des Beweises
wurde also sozusagen
schon am Anfang hineingeschmuggelt.
Darum kann man den Beweis
auch zirkulär nennen.
Man begründet A mit B, B mit C
und C wieder mit A.
Die ganze Begründung
dreht sich quasi im Kreis
und alles
hängt letztlich in der Luft.
Jetzt kennt ihr
ein paar wichtige Fehlschlüsse.
Mein Tipp: Versucht sie
beim Argumentieren zu vermeiden,
und fallt v.a. nicht in die Falle,
wenn jemand versucht,
euch mit diesen Argumenten
zu überreden.
Wenn ihr noch mehr Hunger
nach Philosophie habt,
abonniert den Kanal.
Ciao zusammen!